profesor aún maxwell cameron del
departamento de ciencias políticas de la
universidad de columbia británica los
sucesos ocurridos recientemente en el
capitolio de eeuu han dado lugar a la
presentación de parte de la bancada
demócrata en la cámara baja del
capitolio de un pedido de remoción del
presidente de eeuu qué lectura hacia
usted de esta situación
me da la sensación de lo que ha pasado
en eeuu es bastante parecido a lo que en
américa latina' podríamos describir como
un autogolpe que ha sido un intento por
parte del presidente de utilizar su
poder utilizar su posición
para impulsar una movilización contra la
legislatura contra el congreso tratando
de alterar su deliberación de tal manera
que puede permanecer en el poder y
entonces ahora le toca al congreso
responder y la respuesta ha sido por un
lado pedir al vicepresidente que asume
el mandato presidencial temporalmente
hasta que puede yo para asumir la
presidencia con el respaldo por supuesto
de una mayoría de su gabinete y en el
caso de que el vicepresidente no acepta
entonces proceder con un esfuerzo de
tachar
al presente
round un proceso que se puede iniciar
aunque indudablemente no se puede
concluir antes de el 20 de enero cuando
pare en asumir la presidencia
precisamente eso quería preguntarle
faltando tan poco tiempo para que el
presidente electo deba asumir su cargo
estamos hablando del 21 de enero estamos
hoy a día 11 faltan solamente 10 días
tiene realmente sentido iniciar un
proceso de impeachment como se dice en
la legislatura de eeuu para remover al
presidente en esta instancia tiene
sentido solamente
términos de una preocupación
por el estado
y psicológico del presidente su
comportamiento ha sido provocador ha
sido en contra de las leyes la
constitución ha sido posiblemente
criminal de tal manera que hay una
angustia hay una preocupación qué más
puede hacer no entonces yo creo que hay
una lógica cortoplacista de buscar
evitaron una situación similar a lo que
ha ocurrido en el 6 de enero pero yo
creo que la problema más de fondo es de
largo plazo que tiene que ver con el
derecho o no de donald trump postular a
la presidencia en el futuro y también
tiene que ver con la actitud de los
congresistas quienes han apoyado el
intento de efectivamente anular el
resultado de las elecciones de noviembre
yo creo que más la preocupación en el
largo plazo va a ser eso y ahí hay una
cosa más encima yo diría pensando en la
experiencia de perú después del
autogolpe de alberto fujimori los
fujimoristas que sin duda son la fuerza
más importante y un perú de términos
políticos en la época post fujimori
han sido estigmatizado por su
participación en el gobierno de alberto
fujimori en el padre y la hija keiko
puede lanzarse pero la gente tiene muy
poco confianza porque duda que pueden
gobernar de una manera democrática y yo
creo que un poco de sin duda nos queda
con los republicanos ya que el conflicto
es un conflicto
dentro del partido republicano entre los
que son realmente demócratas con d
min y buscar a los que están encontrando
y no les importa las reglas de juego
están dispuesto de buscar cambiar una
lección qué estilo perfectamente libre y
justa
ahora cuando estos acontecimientos
ocurrieron o hasta que estos
acontecimientos ocurrieron realmente
hubiésemos sido muy pocos los que
pensábamos con la situación tal podía
plantearse en eeuu y cuando comenzamos a
hablar usted dijo que esos sucesos les
recordaban de alguna manera a los
intentos de golpe de estado ocurridos en
otros momentos y no tan lejana mente en
américa latina que ha cambiado en lo que
siempre ha sido señalado como la
democracia más fuerte de occidente para
que estos hechos puedan ocurrir
bueno lo que yo diría es que por un lado
es un acontecimiento muy triste nunca
nunca yo pensé que iba a ocurrir en eeuu
acontecimientos de esa naturaleza lo
hemos visto en perú en guatemala rusia
algo similar en venezuela en turquía en
algunos otros otros países personas y en
estos casos el régimen es mucho más
nuevos y más precarias como bien bien ha
dicho
eeuu tienen una larga trayectoria de si
no de democracia porque realmente no es
un país tan democrático si tomamos en
cuenta la exclusión por ejemplo de la
población negra durante muchos muchos
años pero si un sistema de gran
referencia de gran admiración a su
propia constitución no y la condición
sin hecho sin sin duda es un documento
histórico porque en un momento de
monarquías absolutas
en un contexto de grande confianza
acerca de la posibilidad de tener
gobiernos democráticos eeuu fue pionero
en la innovación de construir un sistema
republicana representativa con
separación de poderes organizada en
términos de presidencialismo no o sea de
una elección del presidente y una
elección separado del congreso dentro
del sistema del imperio de la ley y ese
sistema ha durado durante más de dos
siglos entonces lo que está en juego
aquí es la calidad de la democracia pero
también los fundamentos constitucionales
de la república y esto es lo más
sorprendente no de que ha llegado a ese
punto
en canadá se está hablando de la
posibilidad de caratular al grupo
político proud voice como una
organización del tipo terrorista como
'la nostra o al qaeda y otras
instituciones u otros otras entidades
mejor dicho de ese tipo y también en
algunos casos hay quienes enseñarán que
los sucesos ocurridos en eeuu no son tan
difíciles de ocurrir en canadá usted
está de acuerdo con esta apreciación
si no yo no creo que debemos ser
soberbios no nos diremos no debemos
imaginar que somos moralmente superiores
a nuestros vecinos al sur somos muy
parecidos muchos aspectos e incluso en
el grado no en el grado pero en el hecho
de que hay una polarización política en
el país
y hay el impacto de los medios sociales
hay en las guerras culturales y que si
quieres llamarlos así entonces hay
elementos parecidos pero lo que existe
en canadá y lo que yo siento que está
perdido mucho en eeuu es una idea del
bien común local que nuestro país sigue
siendo un país en donde hay formas de
las grandes diferencias regionales y
otras diferencias sin embargo tenemos
por ejemplo un sistema de salud
al nivel nacional lo público
gratis y abierto al público tenemos un
sistema de educación público también de
buena calidad
y tenemos otros elementos medios de
comunicación como es el cbc
corporación carencia de
no
estos son elementos que yo creo que no
está
en la posibilidad d
tener una respuesta a la pandemia que ha
sido bastante más exitosa no el gobierno
coreano tiene capaces la capacidad de
convocar al público y hay un nivel de
confianza en el entre el público y las
instituciones públicas y los políticos
cosa que evidentemente hoy en día existe
muy poco en eeuu entonces yo creo que
hay todavía tenemos elementos pero hay
que siempre reconocer de que la el bien
común es algo que hay que construir hay
que construirlo a través de la práctica
de ciudadanía y la participación
democrática y la buena representación a
través de los partidos pol&i públicos y
políticos y ahí estos son otros de los
grandes diferencias tenemos más partidos
y no esos partidos hasta ahora han
comportar comporta compartan se como más
de una forma democrática que el partido
republicano que hoy en día francamente
es un partido antisistema
y antidemocrático
para que republicanos y profesores no
quería terminar nuestra conversación sé
que usted es además un estudioso también
sobre el tema de venezuela y en los
últimos días ha habido un
pronunciamiento por parte de la unión
europea de quitarle el apoyo al titular
de la asamblea legislativa de ese país a
juan guaidó como presidente en ejercicio
un presidente paralelo al
elegido en las elecciones llevadas a
cabo en ese país
canadá por el contrario mantiene aún su
apoyo o por lo menos no se ha
pronunciado en el mismo sentido que la
unión europea cree usted que la
situación en venezuela ha cambiado de
manera tal que de canadá debería
y tomar posición una posición distinta a
la que ha tenido hasta el momento
si ofrece el apoyo para cuando no sea la
reconocimiento de waldo como el líder
democrático más legítimo quien tendría
un mejor derecho
a reclamar reconocimiento como desde la
comunidad internacional como
representante de su pueblo pero algo
porque había una asamblea nacional
elegido evidentemente tenemos
prácticamente hoy obviamente el gobierno
de maduro quito este asamblea de su
mayoría que tenía pero sin embargo era
elegido en elecciones razonablemente
libres y ya no la posición una mayoría
igual no era la expresión de esa mayoría
en la legislatura
y como el presidente carecía de
legitimidad entonces yo creo que era
natural tratar de aguayo como si él
fuera el presidente y no ven más más de
los demócratas ahora que han habido
elecciones nuevas y ya no hay este este
institución democrática yo creo que él
le toca le corresponde a la comunidad
internacional no de personificar la
oposición democrática sino apoyar a toda
la oposición y reconocer que why do
podría ser un factor importante y
eventualmente podría ser candidato para
la presidencia podríamos negociar con él
pero en este momento no hay nadie que
puede decir realmente que tiene ese
legitimidad electoral
profesor maxwell cameron del
departamento de ciencias políticas de la
universidad de columbia británica en
canadá muchas gracias por esta
entrevista con radio canadá
internacional gracias gracias a ustedes